vous avez pris conscience que ça allait
trop loin c'était en 2015
mais qu'est ce qui se passe une main
soir il m'a tapée enfin sahel et les
violences ont été beaucoup plus
puissante
j'étais enceinte il m'a séquestrée il
m'a étranglé j'ai donc un coup de poing
enfin les matières et les cheveux il m'a
insulté ben voilà et ça a été l'horreur
j'ai je pense que c'était par instinct
de survie je ne pourrais pas l'expliquer
et j'ai réussi à m'enfuir et
j'ai été hospitalisée en urgence donc
j'étais enceinte et pour sauver le
l'accouchement a été déclenché et les
médecins ont déclenché l'accouchement ce
lot de placenta s'est déplacé sous la
violence des exactement c'est certain
donc en fait j'avais développé je pars
entré dans les terres mais j'ai
développé une prééclampsie et la
prééclampsie on en meurt et pour en
s'offrant guérir faut sortir le foetus
de la mer sauf que ma fille n'était pas
viable
donc je suis resté confiné pendant 18
jours pas de vie
voilà je passe tous ses détails la pas
fine apple c'est qu'elle elle s'en est
très bien sorti l'accouchement s'est
bien passé mais ça a été déclenchée elle
est née prématurément papa grande
prématurée mais la lni pourriture
pourquoi pourquoi il en est venu à ce
point-là de telles violences en 2015
alors que vous étiez censés c'est quoi
là aussi c'était à la suite d'un
événement non non tu es fin ce soir la
gelée surpris en fait en train de
consommer des drogues et de l'alcool
chose que je ne savais pas et donc je
n'ai rien dit en fait c'est dégueu
l'edhec gelé surpris s'est jeté sur moi
donc je sais même pas le dispute ya il
n'y a pas d'élément s'il n'y a pas une
mauvaise parole et qui aurait pu amener
ça c'est rien mais j'ai eu des
événements ou même en simple par exemple
je me reposais sur le canapé je dormais
même il
il est rentré en furie il m'a inventé
parce qu'on devient folle en même temps
il m'a inventé que ça faisait une heure
qui m'appelait qu'il a dû marcher six
kilomètres parce qu'il tombe en qu'il
est tombé en panne
c'est alors qu'il y avait rien mon
téléphone n'a jamais sonné ya enfin même
s'il avait bien évidemment que je
l'aurais dépanner mais en fait on
devient finlande vient à douter de soi
même et c'est ça le plus laid est ce que
c'est lui qui a raison parfois ce que
j'étais
cette faute et quelques pages et
peut-être à la malle fait quelque chose
et on se remet à alençon en question
mais c'est ce que je dis encore une fois
et il n'y a aucune excuse à la violence
y à rien s'est dit ni mauvais j'aimerais
juste te dire que les violences faites
aux femmes augmente pendant la grossesse
et c'est un moment où on fait les femmes
sont encore plus victimes de violences
donc c'est un moment où peut-être nous
aussi moi j'en fais partie profit celle
de santé je le dois aux métiers du
médecin je le rappelle on doit poser des
questions j'ai ma femme qui est sa
chamelle pause lors de la première
question lorsqu'une femme est enceinte
comment ça se passe avec votre mari
questions ouvertes parce qu'il est
gentil et donc peut-être que ça libère
la parole de la femme souvent un bijou
et tout va bien il s'occupe de moi et on
a des enfants
mais il faut que nous professionnels on
est peut-être aussi une prise de
conscience mais
pas nous qui avons les clés c'est le
gouvernement on a des gens qui sont élus
pour ça ils sont payés pour trouver des
solutions
là on parle les 1 millions d'euros il
faut un milliard
je vais pas faire la démagogie mais
quand il faut supprimer les sf ont fait
très vite ça coûte 2 3 milliards ça
faire venir les gens on va relancer
l'économie si on veut sauver des femmes
on peut aussi mettre un peu d'argent moi
je suis effaré par ce chiffre parce que
ce chiffre est constant si on était sur
la bonne pente
c'est horrible une mort est une mort
mais s'ils ont passé de 106 à 90 80 70
on se dirait on est dans une bonne
dynamique là c'est absolument pas le cas
faire gober le problème il est là c'est
que nous on donne beaucoup de son
féminisme mais habillez-vous comme si ne
fait pas ça ah non le féminisme c'est
d'avoir des poils sous les bras
le féminisme césar et finalement on noie
le message même s'il est des messages
très important mais il serait peut-être
temps de faire de réels efforts de
mettre de l'argent parce que je pense
que le nerf de la guerre c'est de
l'argent et je vais vous donner un
exemple très bête très concret j'admire
urgentiste qui a reçu une femme qui se
fait tabasser par son conjoint un
conjoint d'un mètre 90 il l'a vu balèze
il l'a vraiment défigurer les mains cas
c'est tout et elle elle a eu le malheur
de lui mettre un coup de poing parce
qu'elle faisait du karaté elle est toute
menue à faire un mètre soixante pour 50
kilos elle a réussi à lui mettre un seul
coup mais elle a bien visé parce qu'elle
fait du karaté donc il a eu un coquard
lui qu'est ce qu'il a dit aux policiers
écoutez moi j'ai peur pour ma vie et
fait des arts martiaux au fait des arts
martiaux
c'est une arme par destination est la
garde à vue le problème il est là et
cette femme était en pleurs devant mon
collègue médecin en lui disant mais vous
voyez je lui ai mis un coup de poing
regardez moi comment je suis je vais
aller en garde à vue bien sûr qu'elle
sera pas condamné mais faut peut-être
qu'on change un peu les choses donc il
ya des situations du quotidien qu'elle
avait des séquelles alors qu'elle avait
les doigts cassés le visage tuméfié et l
avant garde à vue parce qu'elle fait des
arts martiaux donc les sept situations
du quotidien on en a 1 milliard il
serait peut-être temps de les expliquer
pourquoi les éoliennes sur les femmes je
pense qu'il ya des psychopathes sur n'a
pas d'explication merina tistics on sait
que les hommes deviennent agressifs
lorsqu'ils sont agressifs et le sont
encore plus donc c'est un moment
d'extrême vigilance à la fois pour nous
professionnels santé et puis pour
l'entourage
il faut aussi qu'on se pose des
questions commencent à se parler qu'on
libère la parole tant mieux le numéro de
téléphone c'est très bien mais ce que
c'est suffisant je pense pas et karim
l'a dit il faut faire appliquer les
peines malkani quatre ans en prison
c'est bien mais il faut que des gens le
sursis ne doit pas exister sans plus